how do you
feel now that you're not vegan
i feel good what's the difference do you
feel any different or no
um how long were you vegan for seven
years seven
years yeah like strict not super sad you
like cheese every now and then take some
[ __ ] in when sam wasn't around no meat
no never
never never we were in it together like
you weren't like i don't go behind her
back
anything like that no i know you're
walking to 7-eleven you see those slim
jims staring at you brother and you want
to snap into a slim jim
oh i see those those greasy glizzies on
the [ __ ] roller and i just wanna
no i don't i don't do that kind of [ __ ]
like
again it's like it's all about for me
what it was like i went
vegan when i started like going to an
office
and that was a way for me to like almost
like
put up a wall between me and like
everybody else because like
i also didn't like i was sober for most
of the time that i was like at
those places like when i was working
because i didn't want to like make like
any like true like i had friends and
everything but i didn't want like
those things that like tied me to those
places because it was always just like a
pit stop to get to like where i'm at
right now because i just wanted to like
learn everything things to tie you to
those places well so it's like
everybody eats together everybody does
like the same [ __ ] like hey we're going
to go to a restaurant do you want to
come with us like oh no they don't have
anything for me to eat they're like oh
and i don't drink so i can't go to happy
hour i'm just going to go home and
hang out with sam so it was like my way
of just like kind of like ah
i'm good but uh what was it
oh going what were you saying i forgot
about going vegan oh vegan for seven
years
um oh yeah yeah you were saying when
you're up in leo burnett you went vegan
and it was like
it was also a way for you to like
disconnect from the people that were
there yeah and it was also just a way to
like
clear my mind i was like going through a
lot of stuff and i felt like
you know like changing my relationship
with food was a
big way for me to also like get off of
like the old habits that i had and i
just kind of wanted to like
cut that like i don't know it's like a
really like
it's hard to explain because i've never
really like thought about it until
right now but i think the biggest thing
that i enjoyed about like being vegan
was just
i felt like it was something that me and
sam shared together no matter where we
were at because we didn't get to spend a
lot of time with each other because we
were always working but like i always
knew like
wherever she was like we were like in
this thing together
yeah and the thing that broke me was
fried chicken because i had this thought
when i was like oh yeah
do i really want to go the rest of my
life without eating fried chicken
so that's what that's what broke me and
i don't feel any different
i feel you just because you feel the
same yeah i didn't get sick
but i transitioned out of it yeah i
didn't like a lot of people like to like
to hyper and
sensationalize like the difference of
being vegan and not being vegan
i mean i i don't know any of the science
i don't know any of the research i don't
know
whatever but like i don't feel any
different i feel
good i'm eating
also it feels good grateful too that
like a lot of like one of the things
that always really bothered me about it
was like
say you'd go somewhere and somebody
would make something for you like oh we
made this
and then you have to say oh i'm vegan i
can't eat that
thank you for your generosity but please
just put it in the trash i'm not going
to touch it
yeah and that was something that always
really bothered me like having to say
no to people's generosity and
i think that's the thing that i'm most
grateful for like
transitioning back into just eating
whatever
yeah i i mean i i get it i feel like i i
mean
i hate eating like sweet pea loves
buying
the [ __ ] like publix chicken breasts
that are like this
big oh no they was injected with all the
most [ __ ] up [ __ ] what animals did
this come from
yeah some [ __ ] chicken on steroids i
hate i always feel like she eating that
but she loves buying it
but she doesn't like she's a good deal
it's a great deal they were a bogo
it's a good deal you gotta look past it
it's a good deal
like i don't know i feel like eating for
me
eating like chicken's okay like i don't
mind chicken chicken all tastes the same
it tastes like
whatever depends on what sauce you put
on it yeah sauce but like
sauce dripping dripping sauce on it on
the chicken
but like like eating like a good
steak to me is like eating a dessert
yeah it's like it's
so [ __ ] good it stands on its own it
doesn't need anything yes
you don't even need anything like i
could just eat like like going to uh
ruth chris with mark just ordering the
[ __ ] big
t-bone or the uh the rib eye with
that garlic sauce butter all over it
dude like there's nothing better than
just eating
just a big [ __ ] juicy piece of meat
with nothing else
there's something really cool about just
like
eating with a knife too because that's
something you don't really do when
you're
vegan yeah because everything like it's
like a lot of beans a lot of greens
you know a lot of veggies so it's all
just like bowls and grains and
all you don't really need a knife for
anything have you ever gotten like blood
work done
and like i looked at it yeah you do it a
lot uh
well i had a health screening at one
place that i worked at when i was vegan
and it came back like
[ __ ] a1 really the healthiest [ __ ]
person in there
really and then i got it done again like
a couple weeks ago
after i've been eating meat for like a
year and it's like everything's still
like same
yeah that's interesting i got mine done
a couple like a month or two ago
and i had super high cholesterol and
i'm like the healthiest i'm like like
the
you're on it i'm super honored with what
i eat yeah i pay
more attention to what i eat than
probably anything else yeah i'm very
conscious conscientious about what i eat
what i put in my body and everything and
i try not to eat [ __ ] trying to eat
carbs
i try to only eat vegetables and meat
and i had really high cholesterol so i'm
like what the [ __ ]
so i emailed this guy that had the
podcast this guy dom who's uh
um oh yeah the the scientist nutritional
scientist the weightlifter
he's like yeah the guy who deadlifts
yeah he's the the only person i know
who's dedicated his life to nutritional
science and how it affects your body
the cool thing about him like he's his
test subject yes and he tests everything
himself
he literally tests all these products on
himself and tests his blood every single
day
to the molecule to the [ __ ] whatever
it is
and uh i was i was texting him back and
forth about i'm like dude i'm like
freaking out like i'm gonna have a heart
attack any day now my cholesterol's
through the roof or whatever
and i found out he's like cholesterol is
a myth
he's like high cholesterol is not bad
it's like it's been this thing this
propaganda
that people have pushed on us like for
years that high cholesterol
automatically relates to heart disease
disease when it's not
because there's a lot of he's basically
he was showing me that he basically sent
me all these studies
of these crazy athletes that do like
that are like
marathon runners and triathlon people
who are super super keto and all they
eat is meat and they don't eat any carbs
or whatever
and these are like people that run
10 miles a day when they're not doing
marathons on their off days it's a
casual attack and they have super high
cholesterol
hmm i wonder why that is but it's like
some sort of like
i don't know i guess it's like a genetic
thing or whatever but his whole thing
was with all his studies he's been he's
come up with the hypothesis that
cholesterol is not bad
it's a it's a myth that's good like you
know what
it's not bad it's not not anymore i'm
gonna go ahead and say not bad but a lot
of people
a lot of people agree with him though i
mean he's just like a a scientist that
people can agree with now it's like he
comes out as like
it's not bad and it's like see told you
yeah now he's like
that person yeah that was weird who
[ __ ] knows
who [ __ ] knows man everyone's
different and that's the thing too it's
like you can't
just do what you think is good because
it works for somebody else you got to do
like what's good for you at the end of
the day like
what makes you feel good yeah what does
[ __ ] bud light
bud light bud light cold beer on a
friday cold beer some
tealing and some liquid death you know
what makes me feel good what makes you
feel good luke
a pair of jeans that fit just right cold
beer on a friday night
and you know what i'ma turn that radio
on luke stir let your hair down i'm
letting my hair down
oh boy and a little time out we should
make our own country song
what's up world you just watched a clip
from one of our exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly pure
uncut content straight from the jungles
of columbia if you want to watch the
full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
[Laughter]
peace